Quindi cominciamo con i benefattori, con le persone verso le quali abbiamo un senso di gratitudine e possibilmente verso le quali non abbiamo nessun cattivo sentimento.
Solo un benefattore.
May you be safe.
May you be well.
May you be happy.
che vivete contenti e a paura con il mondo permettendo che quell'immagine sfida
Permettete a quell'immagine di dissolversi.
Contattate quella benevolenza all'interno del nostro cuore.
Portate nei vostri cuori tutte le persone che vi sono care.
May you be safe.
May you be well.
May you be happy.
vivete contenti e a paura con il mondo permettendo che queste immagini sfumino
Permettete a queste immagini di dissolversi.
Sentite questa benevolenza nei nostri cuori.
E portate ai nostri cuori tutti quelli che sono amici e persone a lavoro.
Portiamo nei nostri cuori tutti coloro che sono nostri amici, persone sul posto del lavoro.
May you be safe.
May you be well.
May you be happy.
May you live contented and at peace with the world.
permettete a quelle immagini di svanire sentiamo di nuovo questa benevolenza nei nostri cuori
Portiamo nei nostri cuori una persona che vediamo ma non conosciamo, potrebbe essere un vicino.
May you be safe.
May you be well.
May you be happy.
Permettete a questa persona di dissolversi
sentendo nuovamente questa benevolenza nei nostri cuori e portando questa benevolenza, rivolgendo questa benevolenza verso noi stessi
Offriamo a noi stessi delle benedizioni.
May I be well.
May I be safe.
May I be happy.
May I live contented and at peace with the world.
Adesso portiamo nei nostri cuori di benevolenza una persona con la quale abbiamo un rapporto difficile e cerchiamo di offrirgli almeno un non danno, non fargli del male.
may you be safe may you be well may you be happy
May you live contented and at peace with the world.
Avendo praticato la metta nei particolari, adesso possiamo cominciare a irradiarlo in un senso più generale.
Innanzitutto, all'un l'altro, qui in questa stanza, ai nostri compagni spirituali.
May we be safe.
May we be well.
May we be happy.
potremmo vivere contenti e a paura con il mondo continuando a raccontarlo a tutte le persone in questo distritto
Continuate a irradiarlo a tutte le persone in questa zona.
Che si facciano delle cose abili o non abili.
May you be safe May you be well
may you be happy may you live contented and at peace with the world
radiando a tutte le persone in Italia.
Puoi essere sicuro.
May you be well May you be happy
may you live contented and at peace with the world continuing to read it out to all the people in Europe
Continuate a radiare a tutte le persone in Europa.
Siamo sicuri.
May you be well May you be happy
Se continuate a radiare a tutte le persone nel mondo
May you be safe.
May you be well.
May you be happy.
May you live contented and at peace with the world.
Solo per un momento portate alla vostra mente quelle persone che stanno soffrendo in un modo o nell'altro.
E offrite loro il vostro desiderio per la fine della loro sofferenza.
portate alla vostra mente tutte le persone che provano gioia per un motivo o per l'altro in questo momento e offre a loro il vostro desiderio che la loro gioia continui
e offrite loro il vostro desiderio che la loro gioia continui e cresca
Adesso possiamo cominciare a irradiare la nostra benevolenza a tutti gli esseri, in tutte le direzioni, usando il nostro mantra, il nostro canto, SABBE SATTA SUKHITA HONTU.
Usatelo come un veicolo per esprimere questo vostro atteggiamento, questa attitudine verso tutti gli esseri.
Quindi lo cantiamo nella direzione di tutti gli esseri quindi davanti, dietro, a sinistra, a destra, sopra e sotto.
Lo faremo tre volte.
E poi tre volte per tutti gli esseri in tutte le direzioni.
Esprimete questa recitazione dal cuore.
SAVE SATA SUKHITA HONDUR SAVE SATA SUKHITA HONDUR
Sāve sātā sukītā hantu Sāve sātā sukītā hantu
Sāve sātā sukhi tā hantu Sāve sātā sukhi tā hantu
Sābe sātā sukītā hāntu Sābe sātā sukītā hāntu
SABHE SATHA SUKHITA HANTU SABHE SATHA SUKHITA HANTU
Sāve sātā sukītā hāntu Sāve sātā sukītā hāntu
Sābe sātā sukītā hāntu Sābe sātā sukītā hāntu Sābe sātā sukītā hāntu
Sābe sātā sukītā hāntu Sābe sātā sukītā hāntu
continue that now inwardly continuatelo a farlo da lì dentro
Ora faremo il nostro piccolo esercizio per aumentare la nostra determinazione portando a mente una caratteristica del carattere che vediamo come insolita e possiamo fare queste quattro fasi di determinazione
I can I am able to resist the temptation I ought to for my own benefit and the benefit of others I want to and remember you have to encourage yourself sometimes there
Ricordate che qualche volta lì vi dovete incoraggiare un po'.
E infine, quando questa tentazione sorgerà, io la resisterò.
Posso, dovrei, voglio e lo farò.
portando una virtù nella mente che vorremmo sviluppare di più.
Quindi, nuovamente, io posso, io sono in grado di svilupparla.
Io dovrei farlo per il beneficio mio e degli altri.
Voglio
E ogni volta che sorge l'occasione io svilupperò quella virtù.
Posso, dovrei, voglio e lo farò.
Quindi per un'ultima volta rivolgiamo questo flusso di benevolenza verso noi stessi.
Questo raggio.
May I be free of greed and selfishness
Che io possa essere libero dalla avidità e dall'egoismo.
Posso essere libero o libera dall'odio e dalla malevolenza.
Posso essere libera dalla paura e dall'ansia.
Posso essere libera dall'ignoranza e dall'illusione.
Posso essere gentile, sensibile, comprensiva e benevola.
possa io essere indulgente e compassionevole possa io essere gioiosa e possa gioire del successo di altri possa io essere tranquilla e calma
che io possa essere libera da tutta la mia sofferenza che io possa provare la pace e la beatitudine del Nibbana e radiare questa buona volontà a tutti gli esseri in tutte le direzioni
E irradiando questa benevolenza tutti gli esseri in tutte le direzioni possano tutti gli esseri essere liberi dall'avidità e dall'egoismo.
Possano tutti gli esseri essere liberi dall'odio e dalla malevolenza.
Possono tutti gli esseri essere liberi dalla paura e dall'ansia.
Possono tutti gli esseri essere liberi dall'ignoranza e dall'illusione.
Possano tutti gli esseri essere gentili, sensibili, comprensivi e benevoli.
Possano tutti gli esseri essere indulgenti e compassionevoli.
Possano tutti gli esseri essere gioiosi e gioire del successo degli altri.
Possano tutti gli esseri essere tranquilli e calmi.
Possono tutti gli esseri essere liberi dalle loro sofferenze.
Possono tutti gli esseri provare la pace e la beatitudine del Nibbana.
SABBE SATTA SUKHITA HONTU
sabe satta sukita hantu sabe satta sukita hantu sadhu sadhu sadhu